hello everyone its Perry back here with
another exclusive Collider interview and
yes I am pumped right now because I'm
talking to Nicole from too hot to handle
how are you doing is everything good I'm
good everything is great even though
we're in quarantine my spirits are still
high and I'm super excited this is going
to be an amazing experience and I can't
wait to have everyone watch the show
because it is amazing I am holding back
I'm not saying any spoilers right now
but I have watched all eight episodes
and your spirit should be high because
there's a lot of very serious stuff
going on right now but I am a firm
believer that it's a very important time
for entertainment and you guys it's just
like between the crazy moments and
actually seeing people change the show
just kind of filled my freaking heart
yes and yeah I think it's crazy how
everything happens for a reason there's
a reason that this show came out at a
time when people need positivity they
need like something really good and
entertaining to watch and I think it's
quite fitting with things that are
happening at the moment and but yeah it
was so much fun doing the show you know
there's a lot of things that go on so I
think the viewers they're just gonna
love it
hi I can't agree more so yeah it got
involved in in the audition process for
this did you ever picture yourself on
any sort of whether it was just a
reality any old reality show a game show
a dating show anything like that I have
for maybe the past few years wants to do
something like this and push when this
came my way and finding out it was for
Netflix I was like oh my goodness this
is gonna be amazing this is the goal
this is my dream and so I'm super lucky
and super privileged to have done an
opportunity like this not only to you
know get to do something with Netflix
but the experience itself was something
so amazing and personal to me personal
to everyone else who was on the show and
you don't get an excuse
like that with a lot of shows a lot of
reality shows it was like a real retreat
and I definitely came out a changed
person which is insane to do a show and
then just come out a completely better
person so I'm delighted you just
answered one of my other questions
because I'm so afraid that some folks
out there and I know this is the hook of
the show I'm so afraid some people are
gonna brush it off when oh like just a
show where you can't have sex but
there's yes there's more to it there
really is a change and some really
important lessons learns that I think
yes with you yes like even throughout
the whole process and like we went in
completely blinded to the fact that
there was gonna be this huge twist like
a genuinely serious we had no idea so
when that hit like people will see our
reactions we were in complete shock and
and we were like how come you know this
is happening I thought we were going to
just do bits and have fun but like it
really changed everyone individually it
was like yes in a way it's hard not to
do anything but like when you're stuck
in that situation it's hard for the
public to imagine how you can genuinely
feel even though you're like oh these
ten hot singles are in this amazing
Villa like come on they're having the
time of their lives
yes we did but there was so many because
you're left to think about certain
things about yourself and Lana really
reiterates that and lets you have time
to open up and because if I was just
back home I would never have that time
to reflect on Who I am as a person same
with other people in the retreat but
having that time and when you're in
there it all just comes to a head and
you just get so overwhelmed with things
that we were constantly pushed down to
the surface so yeah like it was
definitely an eye-opener for all of us
today I'm Alana in your sleep now oh I'm
not even joking in from like when I came
out like Lana was just in my ear the
whole time even if I would go out and I
would be talking to boys like hey Lana
is in your head Nicole remember
so Lana has taught me a lot of things so
I got her to kind you said you didn't
know anything about the big twist going
into the show what did you think the
show was when you first signed up how
was it originally pitched to you so you
know they said it was a dating show so I
instantly assumed okay love island bites
maybe I go in boy my commitment a
boyfriend my parent parents are
constantly saying Nicole when you're
getting a boyfriend like come on and I'm
like no hon I'm just having fun / yay so
I just thought you know okay I'll do
this I might find someone then
interested a complete turn and it's the
complete opposite in terms of how I
pictured myself finding someone and
because you know you're not allowed to
do anything so yeah I thought I was
gonna find someone and you know we had
bits and pieces of people but people
have to stay tuned and watch how my
journey turns oh absolutely
so when you audition for a show like
this what do they have you do how do
they know you are a right fit for this
particular concept so in terms of the
audition process it was over a few
months and we had different interviews
with the team and they were asking lost
okay like your ideal days when would you
sleep with someone like after what kind
of days and you know are you into
parroting like etc etc just trying to
gauge if we were brief sexual beings
basically so I just thought you know
what that's normal they just want to
know obviously for a regular dating show
had no idea they were trying to find the
people who were well hope mint leaves
where that is not like happy so yeah
they definitely captured the secret so
hats off to them so when you when you
finally figured out what the show really
was were you thinking back to anything
in your audition and you're like oh
thankfully I said that because that
probably took them off yeah literally
not even joking I was going over
everything in my head okay so that's why
they chose me because I said they
thought that and I was like this all
makes sense
now they're on the ball so I have a
couple of silly behind-the-scenes
questions for you because I think about
all the production elements so we only
see some of you eat when you go on those
prearranged dates is there if you should
feel hot to handle kitchen who is
cooking what's going on with that yes
so we had the most amazing food I've
ever had in my life
we had these personal chefs who cooked
us whatever we wanted for breakfast
lunch dinner so for breakfast we would
had like huge fry ups and french toast
pancakes
so we'd wake up at around 8 o clock
kalana would wake us up do you have some
breakfast we'd all get ready then and
then lunch would be just steak we'd
steak all the time in same with dinner
lovely chicken it was amazing I went
back to my little flash in London just
making pasta after and I was just
thinking how have I done this turn where
I'm having steak every day it's now
having $0.60 pasta so the first thing
you did when you got home like was there
anything being away for so long that you
were thinking you know I can't wait to
get back to that one thing so I went
home and I was a bit jet-lagged so I
kinda just chilled in front of the TV
for the first little bit some friends
went for a few drinks well I didn't tell
a lot of my friends I was going on the
show so there was only a small handful
of my friends who knew so until the
trailer drops last Friday none of my Hut
friends at home knew so they're all so
shocked I was inundated with text
messages last Friday they didn't have a
clue where I went last year I just told
them I was going on a work trip and my
phone broke and so they were in complete
shock it's like the craziest reaction a
friend had to this was anyone completely
blown away that this is what you've been
up to
yes so one friend has always told me
they like they always told me Nicole you
need to your reality show you need to do
this that they were like I want to apply
you to do things but I obviously
couldn't tell her that I had done this
not interested so then when she found
out she died she was like oh my goodness
what is going on and a factor through
Netflix this is insane so I had a lot of
comments like that but back to the
production stuff real quick what was the
what was the most difficult thing for
you to adjust to because I don't know I
just imagined I mean I guess I kind of
do this to a point but wearing a
microphone every day or even I think it
was blowing my mind how close to the
showers the cameras were are you
confident thinking like who is nothing
right now so I could bury stash you're
obviously aware and then I'll be
comrades and then it kinda like
gradually die stand your awareness but
yes at the start the share a situation
kind of reset about that cuz I'm
thinking okay this law what's up guys so
we're going to be watching me in the
shower so the production team were like
oh well you know it's kind of blurry -
and a little bit so I start put my towel
over the shower and they were like no
you can't do that so I was like oh my
goodness and then as well like the
forgetting of the mic sometimes up the
stair people will forget to put them on
and whatever and but yeah it was just
getting used to things like that because
I remember like coming out after filming
I was like where's Mike
oh my goodness where's Mike and I was
like I don't need it anymore so the
first 10 contestants who screwed up the
most things production-wise Oh
I think it's a I think it was probably
Khloe Khloe and her mic yeah we did get
a few calls come on I'm so sorry
it's cause when you come onto the
shoulder as well you obviously don't
wear your mic in the shower so then
you're just having the chats with people
and you're like oh sugar
forgot my mic so yeah without spoiling
anything do you have a most memorable
moment from the show that you're really
excited for people to say you know I'll
be so honest there's so many moments
because there's not one particular
moment that stands out to me because
we're filming for so long and it's all
so condensed and this we filmed a while
back so it's like trying to paint a
certain moment I was thinking of this
the other day and I actually can't
there's so many special things that for
instance the Chloe that I share is so
many moments that are so close to my
hair I can't wait for people to watch
because they're really deep and personal
to me personal to Chloe
and so I'm excited for people to see you
know our conversations and our
friendship but yeah I can't think of one
specific thing because the whole
experience was amazing to me so I wish
that we could talk spoilers right now
because I want to tell everybody why I
appreciated your presence on the season
but something to it I can promise
everyone that so what we on Collider is
we're big into talking about movies and
TV shows and scripted stuff in general
so my question for you is if a movie
star could have been a contestant with
you on - - too hot to handle who would
have made you lose the most money and
maybe say you know who I'm obsessed with
Channing Tatum I think he is a beautiful
specimen like if he if he walked in 100
K but it's just gone like that I
wouldn't even have LinkedIn Eilish I
wouldn't be like sorry Lana I'm just
doing this I'm doing me goodbye I don't
think you're alone on that one before
yeah just a couple rapid-fire questions
so our viewers can get to know you a
little better what is the last TV show
you've been watched
Oh Brooklyn nine-nine good good choice
yeah I liked anything clothes like I
have the most clothes as of every single
person I know I buy about four new
outfits a week it's actually worrying I
might have to go to therapy for it I
think we've all got a little bit of that
problem ourselves in particular my shoe
collections a little absurd right now
yeah yeah do you have any pets yes I
just got a puppy the other day a tiny
little miniature - oh you have a
dachshund I've got two dachshunds oh
that makes me so happy yeah they're the
cutest so he's called milo and he's just
a little baby he's so gorgeous so that's
the dog that I had with my roommate here
in London but back home in Ireland I've
got two other dogs I've got a shih tzu
and then I have got and a he's a king
child so he's so cute now I appreciate
at my I've got my cat right behind me
and he is I love it I've got a serious
one for you now what is your biggest
fear overcome Oh
my biggest fear which I'm trying to
overcome it are spiders on Heights so
every time that spiders in my house
instead of trying to call my roommate or
my housemate to come get us I'm trying
to like pick the spider up I don't want
to kill it and just throw it out sighs
and yeah and then Heights I've only
recently learned that I am scared of
heights because I now live in an
apartment block where I'm like near the
top floor so I didn't really realize
that I was scared until a few months
back but I'm trying my best over
comments I hope you do not find any
spiders in high places there yes same
thank you so much for your time today it
was so nice to get to know
and guys I cannot wait for you to see
too hot to handle on Netflix April 17th
do not miss it
binge at all you guys are gonna love it
oh cool thank you again yes I have a
good one everyone like and share this
tank and we will see you soon with more
Collider exclusives